Es ist absolut paradox!
Eine bestimmte Gruppe Roter Riesensterne bereitet
Forschungsteams weltweit schlaflose Nächte.
Denn diese Stern scheinen alt und jung zugleich!
Ihre großen Massen weisen auf ein junges
Alter hin - ihr Sternmaterial dagegen scheint
sehr alt zu sein.
Welches Rätsel steckt dahinter?!
Deutsche Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
haben dieses super spannende Rätsel jetzt
gelöst!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Die mysteriösen Roten Riesensterne wurden
bereits vor vier Jahren entdeckt und sind
seitdem ein großes Rätsel für Astronomie-Teams
weltweit.
Dazu die Physiker Saskia Hekker, die die Sterne
damals mit aufgespürt hatte: “„Die Sterne
schienen gleichzeitig alt und jung zu sein.
Dieser Widerspruch hat mich nicht mehr losgelassen“.
Verschiedene Messungen hatten nämlich sehr
unterschiedliche Ergebnisse hinsichtlich des
Alters dieser Sterne ergeben: Teilweise lagen
die Ergebnisse der verschiedenen Alters-Messungen
unglaubliche vier Milliarden Jahre auseinander.
Dabei ist die Altersbestimmung von Sternen
heutzutage eigentlich gar keine besondere
Sache mehr.
Auch, wenn man ihnen ihr Alter auf den ersten
Blick natürlich nicht unbedingt ansieht,
können Fachleute die Lebensgeschichte eines
Sterns rekonstruieren.
Dazu gibt es mittlerweile verschiedene Methoden,
die äußerst verlässliche Ergebnisse liefern.
Warum also geben die Roten Riesensterne dabei
so einen Widerspruch auf: Sind sie so alt,
wie es ihr Stern-Material andeutet oder sind
sie jung, so wie es ihre Masse nahe legt?
Die Sterne enthalten eher wenig Eisen, was
darauf schließen lässt, dass die Sterne
mehr als zehn Milliarden Jahre alt sein müssten.
Geht man nach ihrer Masse, dürften die Sterne
dagegen nicht älter als maximal sechs Milliarden
Jahre sein.
Ein wirklich stellares Paradoxon also!
Doch ein Forschungsteam vom Max-Planck-Instituts
für Sonnensystemforschung (MPS) hat dieses
Rätsel jetzt gelöst.
Bei ihrer Analyse nahmen die Fachleute die
Mengen an Kohlenstoff, Sauerstoff und Stickstoff
genauer unter die Lupe, die aus den Kernen
der Sterne an die Oberfläche gewirbelt wird.
Aus dem Verhältnis konnten die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler dann Rückschlüsse daraus
ziehen, wie heiß und massereich der Stern
ist.
Zudem geben die Verhältnisse der Elemente
auch Hinweise auf das Alter der Roten Riesen.
Mit Hilfe dieser Spektraldaten nämlich lassen
sich die Vorgänge im Stern-Inneren konstruieren.
Eine wirklich spannende Spurensuche also!
Und das Ergebnis ist verblüffend: Die Fachleute
sind sich sicher, dass die Roten Riesensterne
ihr junges Alter nur vortäuschen.
Demnach sind die Sterne also sehr alt - so,
wie es ihr Sternmaterial schon nahegelegt
hatte.
Dazu heißt es in der Studie: “Diese Sterne
sind massereich, haben aber relativ niedrige
Stickstoff zu Kohlenstoff-Verhältnisse“.
Heißt im Klartext: Die chemische Signatur
der Sterne entspricht denen von Leichtgewichten.
Von Außen betrachtet dagegen handelt es sich
bei den Roten Riesen um Schwergewichte.
Dazu das Autoren-Team: “Bevor sie zu Roten
Riesen wurden, müssen diese Sterne noch vergleichsweise
leicht gewesen sein.
Ihr hohes Gewicht ist somit keine ursprüngliche
Eigenschaft und eignet sich nicht zur Altersbestimmung.
Sie sind in Wirklichkeit alt.“
Doch ihre Entstehungsgeschichte erklärt,
warum die Sterne die Jugendlichkeit vortäuschen.
Wahrscheinlich hat eine Sternen-Kollision
zu der Entstehung dieser paradoxen Sterne
geführt.
Laut der aktuellen Studie sind diese Sterne
nämlich in einer fortgeschrittenen Phase
ihrer Entwicklung mit anderen Sternen verschmolzen.
Zwei alte, aber eher kleine Sterne wurden
so zu einem massereichen Gebilde.
Somit wird auch ihr heutiges hohes Gewicht
erklärt.
Diese Ergebnisse verhelfen den Fachleuten
zu einem besseren Verständnis über die Kollision
und Verschmelzung von Sternen.
Doch das Astronomie-Team schreibt selbst,
dass dieser Erklärungsansatz nicht für alle
untersuchten Sterne zutrifft.
Denn bei manchen passt die bestimmte Masse
gut zu dem Vorkommen der Elemente Stickstoff,
Sauerstoff und Kohlenstoff an ihrer Oberfläche.
Das Forschungsteam mutmaßt, dass diese Sterne
bereits in einer früheren Phase ihrer Entwicklung
mit anderen verschmolzen sind.
Doch bewiesen ist diese Erklärung noch nicht.
Der letzte Stern im Universum - Rote Zwerge
erklärt - Anklicken, Anschauen und Kurzgesagt
abonnieren mega cooler Kanal!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!